but the absurdities will abound I wonder
if it might collapse under the weight of
its own absurdity probably not before a
lot more harm is done but a OSI showed
this the other day because AOC is
getting a little bit jealous
she's envious that all of the black
Ravens politics are getting the
attention and she's not allowed to
participate in those grievance politics
she was she is now redefined Latinos as
black the first thing that still is for
us to talk about racism within our
community and how we fit both how we are
both impacted by racism in the United
States across the world but also how it
exists within our own communities and
you know a lot of times I'll hear people
say okay this is about black lives
matter what about Latinos and I always
say Latinas are black we are we are
after latina and we run an entire racial
spectrum and so we have to have
conversations around colorism and we
have to have conversations about the
African and indigenous roots from which
we come and how that's reflected in
systems of power wealth inequality and
frankly our our political system well
Latinos are black that's the big brain
take from AOC news to me but well it's
pretty interesting I also can't let her
get away with that pronunciation notice
what she does she's speaking perfectly
fine English she grew up in New York Dan
she grew up in a very ritzy town in
Westchester County
so she's speaking English like a normal
person just and you know one thing I
always hear but that dienes is that some
people say that they're either white or
black but what I want to point out is
that ah Tina SIA IR or black why are you
pronouncing it that way well I am
Italian right I'm a battalion extraction
when I decide where I want to go to
dinner some nights do I say okay well
you know we've either get hamburgers or
we can go get you know some some hot
dogs or maybe we can go get italiano ya
know I think I don't know we'll get
whatever you want we can go get a
grilled cheese we get a cup of super
meat well go eat some meat thaliana food
no I don't do that I say Italian food I
don't say okay I want to go maybe I'll
have some escargot tonight
go eat coal say Oh philosophy would be
very good now I speak English the way
that English people talk
same thing with Letty I mean the the
word Latino really what we're talking
about is the word Hispanic that was now
it's politically incorrect to say
Hispanic so you have to say Latino but
but the pronunciation of it is is a
ridiculous performance of this kind of
racial grievance politics and I think
you're gonna see pushback I think
actually AOC is probably going to have
to apologize for this because there is a
little bit of a debate right now going
on on the left between the
intersectional woke people who say that
every racial and sexual minority has to
come religious minority they all have to
combine together and put away their
differences for a second to stop the
oppressive straight white Christian male
who thinks he's a man and so they'll all
get together and kumbaya and then
there's this this kind of older more
Marxist form which you're seeing in
black lives matter which basically says
no Hispanics are not black Colombians
are not black Asians are not black the
black experience is unique experience
and we are going to be a sort of
monolithic unit we're gonna see that
debate PLC is pretty adept at navigating
the waters of left-wing culture so I
don't I don't think she's going to have
to to deal with this you know
necessarily straight forwardly you know
in a direct way but she may have to
apologize she may have to to ease her
way around it
[Music]
[Music]